Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
Satsang with Mooji Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
Okay, well I've entitled this, No More Ideology.
So he's always going to be about that.
So just looking back at this past century,
we've had these three secular ideologies.
And these really, the idea of ideologies really began when writing began.
And of course, for something like 2,000 years or less than that, it was a Christian ideology.
So what we mean by that is that there is some sort of vision in the future to which you're heading, whether it be the promised land,
or you know the final days or whether it be the wonderful communist state etc so here this last century we've had these three so communism posited this the idea that the ordinary person should be the focus of all state activity it should be the commune it should be the society and
As we know from Animal Farm, even though everybody was equal, some became more equal than others.
And of course, if you are, if you have an idea of where you want to go, some sort of vision, you've got to force people there.
So you naturally move towards authoritarianism.
Then the next one, which came sort of after that, was National Socialism.
And if the communism arose as a response, not to industrial society, remember, but to pre-industrial society, the terrible sufferings of the Russian peasants.
The National Socialism.
Come in, Gwen.
Very welcome.
Do you want a chair or a cushion?
You've missed the amazing opening lines.
Yeah, you'll have to catch up, I'm afraid.
National socialism, especially in Germany, was a response to the really atrocious retributions that were demanded after the First World War, which drove the Germans to real absolute poverty.
And there, of course, like all nationalisms, the nation is the focus.
And you have an ideal as to what your nation is.
And of course, when it's wrapped up with racial ideology, then you've got a real hard mix.
And that's what happened, as you know, in Germany.
It wasn't so much in Italy.
or indeed in Spain.
But again, once you have a vision, you've got to force everybody to get there.
And anybody who gets in the way, you basically, well, you get rid of.
So that was the second one.
So the first one was dependent on the people, the commune.
The second one was on the nation.
And now the third one is dependent on the sovereign self.
And that's neoliberalism.
And it came in very, very sneakily.
It came in as an economic program.
It didn't come in as an ideology.
But in fact, at the base of it, there was definitely the understanding that the primary person was the entrepreneur.
And the whole of society should make the market, the free market, their basic platform for the entrepreneur.
And the entrepreneur was, everybody had to be within the market.
If you're not in the market, then you're useless.
You're not part of that process.
And so anybody who made lots of money, like these billionaires, were the heroes.
And the whole idea, of course, is that the money would trickle down.
Well, it has, but it really is a trickle.
And it's all swamped upwards.
So this idea of having some sort of aim, some sort of ideal, the free market at all costs, no matter what,
And then the ideal of this wonderful individual.
So, you know, just to quote Margaret Thatcher, for which she's very famous, you can see the shift, right?
So away from communism, okay?
I think we've gone through a period when too many children and people have been given to understand, I have a problem, it is the government's job to cope with it.
Or I have a problem, I will go and get a grant to cope with it.
I'm homeless, the government must house me.
And so they are casting their problems on society.
And who is society?
So this is the classic one, isn't it?
There is no such thing.
There are only individual men and women and their families.
Note that, families, yeah?
And no government can do anything except through people and people look to themselves first.
So that's a reaction.
But what, of course, is missing out in that equation, which is strange for a scientist, she had a chemistry degree, is that the whole is always greater than the part, the number of the parts.
So if you've got oxygen and hydrogen, well, they're completely separate.
Put them together and you've got this magical substance.
So, of course, when people get together, what you form is community.
And we know from the way that she behaved, she was quite happy to destroy communities in order to get her aim.
But it wasn't so much her specifically.
This was the ideology that the neoliberals brought in.
And if you really want to see how bad it was, I don't know whether you've ever come across the shock doctrine by Naomi Klein.
If you've read that, then you'll see what a horror story it is for places like Chile.
And of course, it was tremendously humiliating for Russia, you know, when they gave up, especially with the Americans going around saying, we won.
I mean, that was really crass.
So this is individuals seeking their own self-interest benefit for the economy as a whole.
Now, that actually goes back to Smith, where he's trying to explain what the so-called hidden hand of the markets are.
Now, even though you're working for yourself, you're actually creating benefit for others.
Now, what I was particularly interested in was this idea of a sovereign self.
So I do my own thing in my own time, in my own way.
And you'll all remember Frank Sinatra.
I did it my way.
So the West has really developed, especially in America and Britain, this idea of the solitary person.
who makes things happen without anybody else, really.
I mean, the fact that they become billionaires on the backs of everybody is immaterial.
They did it, you know.
So it's the same here.
Occasionally people say to me, you know, you've done an amazing job, you know, what a vision.
But there's nothing specifically wonderful about this vision.
Anybody who's been to something like 15 meditation centers like I have knows what a meditation center is supposed to look like.
And of course, the reason why this has happened as it is, is because
When we bought the place, it was already set.
There was already a bungalow there and there was already an annex which ended here where that wall is, you see.
So it was only working with that and then asking people.
It was people's ideas, really.
It wasn't my idea to have a decking, for instance.
That was somebody else said that, you know.
And the fact that we ended up with an accommodation block, again, was people sort of moaning about sharing rooms.
And so everything sort of happened as it were, gently.
The only thing I take perhaps a little bit of credit for is the stupor.
That was my ideological statement, the stupor.
Okay, anyway, there was a wonderful article taken from The Survival of the Richest by Douglas Rushkoff.
It was, and I picked this up and it said, I have to read it.
It's not particularly that long, but it's a good piece of literature.
So he says, so Douglas Rushkoff, okay.
As a humanist who writes about the impact of digital technology on our lives, I'm often mistaken for a futurist.
The people most interested in hiring my opinions about technology are usually less concerned with the building tools that help people live better lives in the present than they are in identifying the next big thing through which to dominate them in the future.
I don't usually respond to their inquiries.
Why help these guys ruin what's left of the internet, much less civilization?
See where he's coming from.
Still, sometimes a combination of morbid curiosity and cold hard cash is enough to get me on a stage in front of the tech elite, where I try to talk some sense into them about how their businesses are affecting our lives, out here in the real world.
That's how I found myself accepting an invitation to address a group mysteriously described as ultra-wealthy stakeholders,
out in the middle of the desert.
A limo was waiting for me at the airport, and as the sun began to dip over the horizon, I realized I'd been in the car for three hours.
What sort of wealthy hedge fund types would drive this far from the airport for a conference?
Then I saw it, on a parallel path next to a highway, as if racing against us, a small jet was coming in for landing on a private airfield, of course.
The next morning, two men in matching Patagonia fleeces came for me in a golf cart and conveyed me through rocks and underbrush to a meeting hall.
They left me to drink coffee and prepare in what I figured was serving as my green room.
But instead of me being wired with a microphone or taking to a stage, my audience was brought in to me.
They sat around the table and introduced themselves.
Five super wealthy guys, yes, all men, from the upper echelon of the tech investing and hedge fund world.
At least two of them were billionaires.
And after a bit of small talk, I realized they had no interest in the speech I had prepared about the future of technology.
They had come to ask questions.
They started out innocuously and predictably enough, Bitcoin or Ethereum, virtual reality or augmented reality, who will get quantum computing first, China or Google.
Eventually, they edged into their real topic of concern, New Zealand or Alaska.
Which region would be less affected by the coming climate crisis?
It only got worse from there.
Which was the greater threat, global warming or biological warfare?
How long should one plan to be able to survive with no outside help?
Should a shelter have its own air supply?
What was the likelihood of groundwater contamination?
Finally, the CEO of a brokerage house explained that he had nearly completed building his own underground bunker system and asked, ''How do I maintain authority over my security force after the event?''
The event, that was their euphemism for environmental collapse.
Social unrest, nuclear explosion, solar storm, unstoppable virus or malicious computer hack that takes everything down.
This single question occupied us for the rest of the hour.
They knew armed guards would be required to protect their compounds from raiders as well as angry mobs.
One had already secured a dozen Navy SEALs to make their way to his compound if he gave them the right cue.
But how would he pay the guards once even his crypto was worthless?
What would stop the guards from eventually choosing their own leader?
The billionaires considered using special combination locks on the food supply that only they knew.
It's crazy, isn't it?
Or making guards wear disciplinary collars of some kind in return for their survival.
Or maybe building robots to serve as guards and workers if that technology could be developed in time.
It's as if they want to build a car that goes fast enough to escape its own exhaust.
I tried to reason with them.
I made pro-social arguments for partnership and solidarity as the best approaches to our collective long-term challenges.
The way to get your guards to exhibit loyalty in the future was to treat them like friends right now, I explained.
Don't just invest in ammo and electric fences.
Invest in people and relationships.
They rolled their eyes at what must have sounded to them like hippie philosophy.
This was probably the wealthiest, most powerful group I'd ever encountered.
Yet here they were, asking a Marxist media theorist for advice on where and how to configure their doomsday bunkers.
That's when it hit me.
At least as far as these gentlemen were concerned, this was a talk about the future of technology.
Taking their cue from Tesla founder Elon Musk colonizing Mars and Palantir's Peter Thiel reversing the aging process or artificial intelligence developers Sam Altman and Ray Kurzweil uploading their minds into supercomputers.
They were preparing for a digital future that had less to do with making the world a better place than it did with transcending the human condition altogether.
Their extreme wealth and privilege served only to make them obsessed with insulating themselves from the very real and present danger of climate change, rising sea levels, mass migrations, global epidemics,
global pandemics, nativist panic and resource depletion.
For them, the future of technology is about only one thing, escape from the rest of us.
It's stunning, isn't it?
Stunning, absolutely stunning.
So that's where we're at.
That's the end game of neoliberalism, the sovereign self.
So what we have, of course, still just about in this country, I think, is a liberal democracy, which is trying to hold, isn't it, the balance between social demands and personal needs and allowing that sort of individual liberty within the constraints of a community.
But as you know, when it comes under pressure,
then you have these two wings come up.
So where can you go now?
What's the next ideology?
We've done the community bit with communism, we've done the nation bit, and we've done the sovereign self.
So there's nowhere else to go, is there?
So you've got to go back.
You've got to either become a communist or a national socialist or keep banging on about being a sovereign self.
We seem to be locked in now in a sort of ideological cul-de-sac.
Can you think of any other ideology that you can hang, any other basis that you can hang an ideology on?
So an ideology, remember, is some futuristic aim that you're going towards and you just make for it.
There's a lovely little tale I heard about.
They had a big communist conference in Moscow.
And it was a French writer, but I just can't recall the name.
But they were talking about the perfect communist state.
What would constitute the perfect communist state?
And he asked, what about accidents?
And seemingly there was a silence.
And then a voice came out from the darkness.
In a communist state, there will be no accidents.
That would be brilliant.
So, and of course the question is...
What can Buddhism offer?
What, you know, like that.
By the way, I have got here, I love quoting this.
I just, I mean, you see it quoted all over the place now.
The second coming by Yeats.
Turning and turning in the widening Gaia, the falcon cannot hear the falcon.
That's wonderful, isn't it?
The rich can't hear the poor, you know, the powerful can't hear that.
And we sort of separate, you know, immigrants or natives can't hear the immigrants and so on and so forth.
Things fall apart, the center cannot hold.
It's great, isn't it?
Mere anarchy is loosed upon the world.
You might have come across Jem Bendell and others trying to work on catastrophe studies.
I think there's actually university departments now, isn't that right, Gwen?
Collapsology.
Collapsology, that's it.
Collapsologists.
There is an actual discipline now.
That's how bad it gets.
The blood-din tide is loosed and everywhere the ceremony of innocence is drowned.
The best lack all conviction, whilst the worst are full of passionate intensity.
And you can see that, can't you?
You can see that the liberal establishment is sort of confused.
It doesn't know what to do about mass immigration.
It doesn't know what to do about the Kleist.
It doesn't have a clear direction, which it would have had, say, after the Second World War.
So somehow we have to transcend this.
And if we go back to the time of the Buddha, there are no ideologies.
You know, because writing, nobody was writing.
There wasn't anything written.
He was illiterate.
And so there wasn't the opportunity to think about thinking.
So there's no systems theory.
There's nothing like that at all.
What there is are customs, laws and customs that have been worked out through ages and ages and ages.
and moral reasoning so if you look at um you know hinduism or jainism or buddhism it's all about the psychology of moral behavior and their language is that so whereas we would talk about the purification of the heart these days it's medicalized it's a therapy to get to get over your internal problem and uh
And we're going to read this at the stupa there.
So if you now put aside any idea that we're going anywhere, right?
So there's no such thing as a perfect society.
There's no such thing as moving towards some sort of future Shangri-La.
It's always going to be like this, right?
There's always going to be misery, suffering, spiced with an occasional bit of joy.
This is what we call samsara.
But we do have an aim, but the aim is completely beyond the phenomenal world.
It's beyond anything that you can imagine.
It's beyond anything that you can create with your mind as a beautiful and wonderful society.
But of course, the fundamental error or delusion that we suffer from is to believe that we are human beings and therefore we do seek happiness in this form, in this world.
And it's because of that that we create all this business about selfishness, which is translated as the sovereign self.
You know, greed is good.
Yeah.
And of course, that creates problems for us.
So we push away, we get rid of anything that we don't like.
So you get the aversion.
If it's too big, you run for it.
So there's your basic fundamental attitudes that arise from that delusion, acquisitiveness, aversion and fear.
And from there, all our actions sort of spread outwards and create a second tier of horror, of shame, guilt, remorse and all the rest of it.
So if we start from a basis of no ideology, in other words, we're not going anywhere to some great, amazing place and instead draw ourselves, like the Buddha would have done, down to his present day situation,
And obviously it wasn't perfect.
For instance, you know, there's lots of talk in the scriptures about these useless, massive sacrifices that were made on the understanding that the gods would respond so long as the sacrifice was done perfectly.
So this had moved away from the time when they were petitions to gods.
where the gods might or might not reply but it came to a point by the time that the buddhas was alive that if you did the sacrifice perfectly we talk about hundreds of cattle hundreds of horses the king's sacrifice then the gods had to sort of reply and of course it probably wasn't working just like in Socrates time people were losing faith in the gods you know
And so it's not as though everything is right at the Buddha's time.
I mean, obviously not.
And there were kings who were creating war and all sorts of messing about.
And there was ordinary crime, etc.
But there was no sort of, as I say, this Shangri-La.
So all the teaching of these religions, of these religions,
These dispensations were always drawn towards the society as it is now and how you could make it better.
And so when it came to the Buddha's own thing, he has quite a bit of advice on what keeps a society together as a community.
And so this is it here.
See, at the time when the venerable Ananda was standing behind fanning him, the Blessed One addressed him.
This had happened because
the son of Bimbisara, whose name just escapes me now, had sent a diplomat or one of his ambassadors to see the Buddha to ask whether this was a good time to attack the bhajis.
I mean, what an interesting question to ask the Buddha.
Is this a good time to attack them?
Well, he didn't actually answer directly, but he gave these sort of things to consider.
And he asks, he asks, so he's asking Ananda, you see.
He says, have you heard, Ananda, that the Vajji Confederacy has frequent gatherings and their meetings are well attended?
And there's a refrain after each of these questions.
I have heard, Lord, that this is so.
So long, Ananda, as this is the case, the growth of the Vajis is to be expected, not their decline.
And then he goes on.
Do the Vajis assemble and disperse peacefully and attend to their affairs in concord?
you know, considering our politics.
Do the Vajis neither enact new degrees nor abolish existing ones, but proceed in accordance with ancient constitutions?
That sounds very conservative, small c, but that would be the basis where you start from.
You accept those and then presumably you'd move from them.
Do the Vajis show respect, honour, esteem and veneration towards elders and think it worthwhile to listen to them?
Have you heard, Ananda, do the Vajis refrain from abducting women and maidens of good families and from detaining them?
So this, of course, you could extend to all the prejudices of, you know, sexual, race, racial, and I may as well plug ageism here.
Well, that's it.
do they show respect honor and esteem and veneration towards their shrines both of those in the city and outside and do not deprive them of due offerings as given and made by them formally so this of course is pointing to freedom of belief freedom of speech and so on and then finally duly protect and guard the other house so that so that they can come to the realm
and live there in peace.
So this is really respecting both religious and civic leaders.
If all these are followed then according to the Buddha then you can expect growth and not decline.
So, I mean, you have to always translate this stuff, of course, into our present day.
But you can see that he's very much about community, about people talking to each other and discussing things, coming to agreements.
And then a passage here where he talks about six things that foster love and respect, helpfulness and agreement, harmony and unity.
So again, this is, you know, just basic ethics.
So he's talking to monks now, but you can translate it, obviously.
when one acts with love towards one's companions in the spiritual life, both in public and in private, when one speaks with love towards them, both in public and in private, and when one thinks with love towards them, both in public and in private, when one shares with them, without reservation, whatever one has acquired justly, even if it be no more than the food in one's alms bowl,
when one possesses together with them virtues that are complete unbroken and freedom giving praised by the wise and conducive to concentration and when one possesses with one's companions in the holy life both in public and in private the understanding that is noble leading to freedom and which conduces to the complete destruction of suffering
Then will there be love and respect, helpfulness and agreement, harmony and unity.
So again, you have to translate this into ordinary daily life.
But you can see the directions are always about ethics, about moral behavior.
And then finally, there's a lovely passage where he meets some Arahats, I think three of them living together, and he asks them, how do they live in harmony, mutual appreciation and agreeability, like milk and water mixed, regarding each other with kindly eyes?
And one of them, Anna Ruda, replied, I always consider what a blessing it is, what a real blessing, that I'm living with such companions in the spiritual life.
I think, speak and act with love towards them, both in public and in private.
I always consider that I should put aside my own wishes and acquiesce to what they want, and then I do that.
Thus, we are many in body, but one in heart, one at heart.
So here we have both an idea of what the Buddha, an approach, what we're interested in is not exactly what he says, but his approach to community, which is to establish that sense of togetherness and the whole business of sharing and of kindly love, etc., etc.
So I think...
I think if we could just for one minute abandon all ideologies and just come down to a basic grounded moral and ethical reasoning, you know, with a present day aim of creating a consistent state of community with everything that word means, you know, that is my hope.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance, that I have not caused even greater confusion or argument, and that you will, by your devotion to practice, liberate yourself and help others liberate themselves sooner rather than later.